camping that we couldn't get it rebound
back history here come the bullocks the
other way your battle will take it in
with a lot of the Florida State defense
well you can say it looks like they have
a break but look at the guys in black
come flying back
[Applause]
it's man over three rebound collected by
Clark hmm I had exhibited support
[Applause]
savoia he was just heated what Hashem or
ran in be able to get into this plate to
me this is a silly found the dunk by ha
Chmura
and then the reaction by Kevin Kelly
once he knew he was B there's the
contact on the backside Turner
behind the back Edwards checks of his
now look at this and know this is not
the perfect situation for Tennessee shot
clock down to 9 fly can't dribble
himself free he's gonna have to take a
long one fine step-back three for the
top
[Applause]
this dude 22 second half points 27 for
the game for Ryan plunge the finches
react actually what they got Moretti
it's moody Maroney tees what a path and
that is an actual dream they get today
as well and this is very interesting you
draw the defense and then you kick it
out to Moretti now he is a really good
three-point shooter
who has not shot the three well so far
at 17 minutes left
[Applause]
first of all they went up high and Owens
quality quantum if you shoot 18 a game
now they're out their heels a little bit
[Applause]
wilee big-time block and he look at this
one being a little strange right now
only just that huh oh my right on the
ball and it's 76-59 over in North
Carolina just not getting into a flow
white the speed and slam and a chance at
three
I can turn the corner and if you just
for a second arm back there waiting for
arm it's way too late
good call from the officials pretty
impressive after crashing to the floor
hitting through free throws
[Applause]
the rim about this big time leave the
chandeliers put the China way with this
guy around the house
rookies say that should be outlawed
because right over ties back to 6:00 the
largest lead of the game at Virginia
Tech and as Jones
[Applause]
sensational Davis curls goes Corey Davis
jr. creativity how bout the crunching of
the basketball just then and reloading
inbounds pass and watch this one down
and four reload on the way down as hit
eight of its first 16 Newton five out of
nine for three this is going to play
here by Watters maze maze Stephen takes
in the distant that look is these just a
winter wrap up their time it on the
floor getting the steal out of
transition time
[Applause]
tough shots wind keeps it alive second
all the debris they set up the basket
because you're a senior you have the
confidence take it even if you're
struggling
that was oppressed informatics 76-59
author the dog Caroline and just not
getting into a flow why the speed and
slap chat to three watch him turn the
corner and if you just for a second arm
back there waiting for him it's way too
late
good call from the officials pretty
impressive enter crashing to the floor
hitting two free throws doing
[Applause]
for the rim about this big-time leave
the chandeliers put the China way with
this guy around the house
rookies say that should be outlawed
because right over ties back Hewlett
ater they're not going to let him get to
the basket takes it drop Jones and I
like that trade Joe not settling up in
the back such a well coach booth but
it's NASA's had too much heat on it
Robinson he's a great lob pass at his
kid coming out his last name is Hill he
finishes strong in transition Virginia
Tech in control
six the largest lead of the game at
Virginia Tech and as Jones
[Applause]
can you go competing inside Washington
turns gives it up Travis off the double
look cheatin
for the jam Washington still has the
lift